welcome to the quick start for cloud
speech to text which converts speech
into text using google's ai technologies
in this video we walk through how to
convert an audio file to text using the
rest interface and the curl command
to get started with cloud speech attacks
you need a google cloud project you can
use an existing project or set up a new
one in the google cloud console at
console.cloud.google.com
visit the apis and services section of
the console and enable the cloud
speech-to-text api for your project
next you need to set up authentication
in the apis and services section click
on credentials
create a new service account and
download the private key as json
you can use these credentials to access
google cloud apis
so make sure to keep this file secure
and out of your code and public
repositories
to securely access the credentials from
your project go to your terminal and set
an environment variable to the path of
your json file
if you don't yet have the google cloud
sdk installed on your machine then
install and initialize it instructions
are linked below
create a new json request file add the
following text and save it as a
sync-request.json plain text file
this json snippet indicates that the
audio file has a flac encoding format a
sample rate of 16 000 hertz and is
stored in a google cloud storage bucket
at the given uri
next use curl to make a request to the
speech.googleapis.com endpoint
this curl command specifies
sync-request.json as the file name of
the json request you just created
run the curl command and you should see
the following response
here we can see the transcribed text as
well as a confidence value that
estimates how likely it is that the
transcription is accurate
and that's it
you now know how to make a call to the
cloud speech to text api using a curl
command
make sure to check out the rest of our
cloud speech-to-text documentation at
cloud.google.com
speech-to-dash
text
docs
[Music]
you